[Music]
the feelings I feel driving
the car
the first and most important
thing for me is that I feel like I'm
not disabled to be like
I was before
[Music]
my name is  frédéric sausset and i'm
a car racing driver
my accident happened in july 2012
i was hit by a bacterium
following a scratch on a finger and this
bacterium was not detected
enough happiness and it
turned into  lightning sepsis and
I lost my arms and my legs
when I realized my condition
it was indeed a shock but the fact
of being very well surrounded but really
really helped in any case to survive
and start a new life
before my accident I never drove
I have always been passionate about
motorsport since my youngest age
but I did not have time to
practice motorsport and when I
had this accident I had the need to
find myself in an incredible challenge  ble is
impossible
with the ultimate goal of going to the 24
hours of Le Mans
for any high-level sport or the
need to train especially me
with my handicap
for the 24 hours of Le Mans I had a
program of more than three hours  per
day so there was a
box management software that was developed on the fly
otherwise the rest specific equipment
that I can accelerate with my
right thigh and Frederic my left thigh
and a specific steering wheel with a
prosthesis barely two and a half years later
I was at the start of the 24 Hours of Le Mans
it is the culmination in the life of a
driver to be at the 24 Hours of
Le Mans and for me even if I have already
managed to do it it remains a dream to
repeat  because it's
something quite incredible
[Music]
the goal is really to compete
with valid drivers and that's
something that is extremely important and
it was extremely important for me
personally to show you that the
handicap n  is not an end in itself
I have worked very hard can prove
that disability has its place in
motorsport and in high-level
sport car racing yes has changed
my whole life the message when these two especially
from  have a dream because only a
dream we sort of pull us forward
and take us to a new life
[Music]